we're looking at similar figures we've
looked at these before so hopefully this
film won't be too strenuous on your
brain so I'm just going to turn this
down a little bit is that's better now
as I mentioned or as I wrote you'll need
a ruler for this not just to make some
straight lines but you're actually gonna
have to do some measurements so what I
want you do is beside your random
quadrilateral you will need some extra
space so I just said to mark just now oh
you've already got pre-drawn columns
that's gonna make this will make it work
that's okay
you're gonna need some space beside your
quadrilateral because we're going to
create one like this that is similar and
we're gonna do in a very particular way
that's really kind of neat I hope you
have a bit of fun with it and we're
gonna work out later on why exactly this
works maybe you can work it out as we do
it okay I would like you to with your
pencil pick a point any point somewhere
around like I'm gonna put mine over here
so the reason why I'm putting mine here
is because I have plenty of space to the
right of my diagram but you could put it
like above if you got space below your
diagram you could put your point above
you could even put your point inside the
diagram inside the quadrilateral you'll
see why later on it actually doesn't
matter where you place it okay
I've placed mine a little bit to the
left now what I want you to do with your
ruler is so watch this carefully I'll
show it up here and then I'll ask you to
do the same okay you've got one two
three four points here let's just name
them let's call them I don't know
something like ABCD that's nice to know
original a B C and D whichever was the
one you labeled as a put your ruler pick
it up right now if you've got it there
put your ruler at the point that you
selected and then I haven't I thought I
had a magnetic one but it's gone place
it so it goes through a okay so you can
see I'm holding my ruler in place it
starts at my spot my random spot over
here and then it goes it reaches up to
my first corner of the quadrilateral a
now when you've got your order in
position I want you to measure that
distance because my diagram is so large
that's 22 centimeters on my diagram
maybe it's 3 or 4 centimeters on yours
okay when you've marked out that 22 or
that whatever distance it is I want you
to double that so for example you might
have measured three and a half
centimeters you double that you're going
to get seven if you measure it out
exactly five centimeters you double that
you're going to get 10 and I want you to
find that spot on your ruler and place
another point there so mine was 22 I'm
gonna double which gives me 44 mark that
spot in okay so we've marked a new spot
it came from a so I'm gonna call this
new one I'm gonna rub this out so I have
some spots around it I'm gonna call this
new spot a - okay if you like having
drawn that out if you've got another
color you can draw the line on which you
drew that so mine would look something
like this okay so if there you go to get
wonky but you get the idea right now I
want you to rinse and repeat so for each
of the corners you've got I want you to
measure two they're double the distance
and place a new point so I'll show you
again how I did that to get to B I'm
gonna hold my ruler like so okay on my
enormous diagram that's 42 so I'm gonna
double and place me at 84 so it's down
here
there we go so because I created this
new point out of B I'm going to call it
no surprises
B - so I've got a new point go ahead
repeat that for C and for D you have
four new points and then once you've got
them all to you what to do them the
first one any way you like any way you
like
so that yeah that first point anyway you
like literally anywhere you like but um
don't put too far away otherwise what
you're gonna do will be hard that's you
okay could you raise your hand if you've
got your a - B - and see - and C and D -
on hands up anyone got all four
excellent you've got a couple still
waiting a fantastic
still waiting for a few more those of
you who have got all four of your new
points what I'd like you to do is just
like you joined up the original dots to
create a quadrilateral I want you to
create a new quadrilateral a - B - C - D
- can you do that for me so yeah so draw
it in the same order that you had ABCD
okay just draw everything up okay that's
really wonky I got to fix that
is it is it all on your page Harry okay
go ahead good that'll do okay so you may
be still going that's fine as you're
doing that let's discuss what we've
created or what you are currently
creating okay what you've done is what
we call a scale enlargement a scale
enlargement by taking each of the
original points measuring out from
wherever and then doubling that distance
okay I want you to now measure something
else these are all be different but I
actually want you to put onto your
diagram measure your length a B wherever
it happens to be so my a B is here okay
so I'm gonna find out what that length
is when you measure that put onto your
diagram so mine is 31 centimeters okay
obviously yours will be smaller so maybe
you want to get a decimal point and
accuracy something like that but now
when you have a look at your new version
your bigger version what you should find
is when you measure here I'm gonna have
to move this a long measure from the
other side if you've done it accurately
your new version should be double it
should be double right mine is 62 okay
how come it's double why not like triple
yeah very good when we did this some new
creation in the new point right this
distance here we doubled it to get to
the new one right you the double this is
from a to get to a - and we've done this
for every single one you could measure
more lap but it's that's not the point
okay
so we've created what we call similar
figures okay
when I speak sorry start again when you
speak I give you my full attention it's
just a courtesy ping you know like what
human being to another I would really
like you to return the favor
Thanks similar figures what we gave is
our heading right you've just created
them what are they how would you
describe like they're not exactly the
same are they that's why we don't say
the same figures what ways are they the
same because they are the same in a lot
of ways what do you reckon
okay scale is something to do with size
right I would suggest that scale is
actually the thing that is different
between these shapes yes so that's
actually important so we might jot that
down so similar figures you can just put
this beside your shape or underneath
you've got no spaces beside it similar
figures have a different scale but in
literally every other way that matters
they're the same they're identical in
every other way so I'm even gonna write
that but they are identical in all other
ways you started with a quadrilateral
you ended with a quadrilateral right
you started with a particular bunch of
angles see how this is like a sharp
angle and this one was like a this one
over here was a wide angle well your
sharp angle becomes another sharp angle
and your wide angle becomes another wide
angle acute and obtuse I should say okay
all the proportions are the same so for
example see my a B for me it looks
roughly double the length of C D ok
roughly anyway okay in my new
quadrilateral a - B - should be double
the length of C - D - so all of the
proportions they're the same okay so
what we've done is created an
enlargement this is our original in fact
I'm gonna label that with the correct
color this is my original over here
does anyone know what the new shape is
called the one we've created that was
different
this guy here it starts with an eye it's
called the UM it's called the image you
may have heard this word from last year
the before okay our image was double the
size but you can create one that's
smaller what we do to create one that
was half the size not double yeah very
good so remember my first measurement
was 22 and so I went to 44 okay well if
I wonder what there was half the size a
little version instead of going in 22 I
would go to 11 right and so you can see
all the distances are going to be I'm
going to create a shape up here okay in
fact if you've drawn out the lines like
I have it doesn't take you much effort
to create the new points along here and
you'll get a small version okay you
remember I said before you could put
your original point any way you like
will imagine if I created the same
that's not the same but you get the idea
imagine if I had the same shape and I
put the point in the middle where will
the image go it's gonna go around
exactly right because you're gonna go
measure here and then you're gonna go
further you're gonna go here and then
further here so you gets kind of like a
spiderweb sort of shape right tada so
there it is okay that's not too bad so
it's still the same deal it's still
enlarged it's still identical in every
way except for scale okay